barbie kalala and shane gillis uh the
first question is not a question it was
actually a common um request on our
twitter and our social media uh people
are saying you have an amazing
surprisingly donald trump impression and
they wanted to see if you could teach
bobby how to do the donald trump
impression he's tried a couple of times
can i hear yours i don't have one yeah
you try to do it right now
i'll mimic you
you try no no no you go first
well just give me a sentence that he
would say and then maybe i'll try uh
let's go uh
uh the greatest uh the greatest country
in the world is america the greatest
greatest country in the world
is
yeah america
was terrible
it was terrible that was terrible
it was like marlon bran
[Laughter]
well i mean say one do the same line and
maybe i can mimic it so you got to do
the easiest way to do trump is like to
speech trump when he's doing a rally
okay okay cause it's just in the
backyard
the greatest country
the greatest country okay a little bit
the greatest country don't do this do
this
the greatest country
don't move at all only move your hand
all right don't don't move my body
yourself your shoulders
if you're the greatest country
sit like that if you're sitting don't
first of all don't
okay so sit like this
yeah
the greatest country
the best country the best country
wow what a country wow what a country
a lot of asians a lot of a lot of asians
maybe too many maybe
yeah
that's pretty good that was good
yeah thank you wow
you blew a gasket i almost died give me
do you do other impressions
no
yeah you must do other impressions that
was so how i was taking that
i watched a lot of trump yeah
i liked it yeah yeah like that bit that
you do about your fox is that true to
your fox news dad yeah yeah of course
i'm exaggerating a little bit yes no i
mean
yeah this was a rough year for
my dad was watching the news a lot yeah
he was fired up that's really funny
he was fired up i mean i
yeah that's how they every dad
yeah getting crushed by [ __ ] fox news
they're getting [ __ ] crushed
i love it every day but i mean there is
the other side of that which there are
like the cnn dads and those guys that
are like
can you believe what's going on
yeah yeah you dude
yeah yeah yeah you know yeah
um
another question yeah we got a question
it's uh hey guys i'm a 20 year old 28
year old male who just can't seem to
find a woman no matter what i was burned
at an early age found my ex in bed with
some random dude when i was 18 and i
have since been alone i've tried
everything i can think of gone out to
bars tried the apps gave up and hoped
that the